hot mugshot guy Jeremy Meeks reconnects  with Chloe green while his wife Melissa  is seemingly moving on with their  families  [Music]  the model who rose to fame in 2014 for  his sexy mugshot appears to be taking  his romance to new heights with the  Topshop eros here's the pair packing on  the PDA in the pool at an LA Hotel on  Friday  later that night Jeremy and Chloe were  spotted hidden hand wearing coordinating  all-black ensembles for a night out on  the town at catch La restaurant  meanwhile his estranged wife Melissa  celebrated her birthday with her mom and  sister the new sighting comes after the  so called world's hottest felon and  Chloe were first caught making out on a  yacht earlier this month after the photo  went viral his wife of eight years filed  for legal separation  [Music]